we have a voicemail number it is two one
nine two david p we have a very angry
caller today who believes that i should
be covering the russia story but I'm
covering the wrong Russia story here's
what this caller has to say
I think he should investigate Hillary
and Bill with Russia hmm
worried about Trump its Hillary and Bill
one took means and millions of dollars
from them for uranium then trade with
Canada right you're all the bucks idiot
yeah okay well um thank you I appreciate
you sharing your perspective on what we
shouldn't shouldn't be covering we've
got a fantastic bonus show for you today
Oklahoma is going to start using
nitrogen for executions this is an
unprecedented move a French Baker has
been fined nearly four thousand dollars
for working too much the French really
take vacation time and reasonable work
hours very very seriously and a judge is
slamming the door on more lawsuits by
the clock boy family if you don't know
what that is
I will tell you on the bonus show two
ways to access the bonus show number one
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership number two become a
patron for as little as five bucks a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and remember free bumper stickers
we've got the white bumper sticker and
the black bumper sticker available to
all new yearly members you can use the
coupon code vote soon eighteen to get a
40% discount and then just email me and
say hey david here's my address send me
one of those bumper stickers